M1: Fox News host Tucker Carlson continues
to tell us that he's not an anti Voxer,
he's said on his show many times lately, I am
not an anti Voxer, but yesterday on his program,
he did a very anti Voxer thing, which is under the
guise of I'm just asking questions and some people
are getting in trouble for asking these questions.
F3: He set up a segment about vaccines basically
the same way that anti vaccines do. And Tucker
Carlson apparently hasn't heard of Google
or medical studies. Check this out.
F5: So all of this should prompt some
pretty tough questions for our public health
experts in this country. And one of those
questions is how effective is this coronavirus
vaccine? How necessary is it to take the vaccine?
Don't dismiss those questions from anti
vaccines, don't kick people off social media
for asking them answer the questions.
F3: So the questions that Tucker
thinks people are getting trouble getting in
trouble for asking our questions that have been
No one discussed and debated and studied for a
year. And number two, about which endless peer
reviewed data is available with a simple Google
search for. His first question was how effective
are the vaccines? We know how effective they
are. The Moderna vaccine is 94 percent effective,
with a 95 percent confidence interval after two
doses at preventing illness. And it is virtually
100 percent effective at preventing severe covid.
The Pfizer vaccine is 95 percent effective,
with a 95 percent confidence interval and is 89
percent effective at preventing serious covid.
The Johnson and Johnson vaccine is 72 percent
effective, but it was, remember, tested later
on the current variants. And probably if you
tested the Moderna and Fizer against the variants,
you would see similar numbers. Those were
tested earlier when there were fewer variants
around. And again, the JMJ also
one hundred percent effective
at preventing serious covid. And then the
AstraZeneca vaccine being rolled out in some
countries is 70 percent effective and 100 percent
effective at preventing serious covid we know
how effective they are. We also know how safe
they are. The rate of anaphylactic reactions,
serious allergic reactions is about zero
point zero to five percent, with everyone that
experienced an anaphylactic reaction recovering
and 98 percent of vaccine recipients have
no allergic reaction at all. Remember that
fever is not an allergic reaction, that that is
the vaccine working. We're talking about actual
allergies here. So we have these answers.
We know the data. No one's getting in trouble
for asking how effective is the vaccine. That's
a great question, because the answer is such a
positive one. And the the and a knowable answer
now, how important is it to take the vaccine?
That's also a fine question to ask. The problem
is that too many people aren't smart enough to
understand the answer and to realize what herd
immunity is and that your personal risk level is
not the only factor in determining whether you
should or shouldn't get vaccinated. Now, I don't
think Tucker is an anti vaccine. And in fact,
my guess is that if he hasn't been vaccinated
already, he and his family all are going to
get the vaccine as soon as they can. I think this
is the show that Tucker is putting on because it
plays well with his audience. I wouldn't again, he
might already even be vaccinated. Tucker is asking
questions that others get in trouble for asking,
but we actually have the answers and no one is
getting in trouble for asking those questions.
People are getting in trouble, so-called,
when they spread nonsense like the vaccine isn't
a vaccine, but a DNA modifier or the vaccine
is microchips or they're planning to roll out
forced vaccinations or whatever the case may be.
The questions, Tucker, are the questions being
asked by Tucker are basic scientific, empirical
questions, and that's that. But if his audience
doesn't realize there are such clear answers
to those questions, then this segment works and
that's what you have to understand. Remember that
when Tucker was sued, one of the defenses
that Fox News lawyers put out there
was that his program is entertainment and he
regularly, regularly uses hyperbole and other
tools of of rhetoric and entertainment, not of
news reporting to make the show interesting.
And viewers should understand that. And of
course, I understand that. I know many of
you understand that, Tucker Tucker's show is
not a news show, but an entertainment show.
But a lot of the Fox News audience doesn't. And
in fact, in fact, Fox News has made a killing,
blurring the lines between what is news and what
is opinion. And one way that they famously in
media studies, this is a notorious thing that Fox
News does. They will take their opinion, hosts
opinions, and then they will report on them during
the news hours and say breaking. Tucker Carlson
asks, Why are people getting in trouble for asking
how effective the vaccine is? That's how they they
deliberately and further blur the lines between
news and opinion. And I know many of you know
this, but much of the Fox News audience doesn't.
And that's why this works. That's why this does.
Well, and, Tucker, for all I know, Tucker is
vaccinated and he's asking these questions merely
as a ploy for ratings and generating interest.
And in fact, this wasn't the only crazy thing
that happened on Fox News in the last 20. For
hours, I want to talk about some of the others